en los últimos años granjas se ha
cosechado alrededor de mil manzanas más
que su principal rival de la región
huerto río grande debido al clima frío
de este año la cosecha abajo en cantidad
por un tercio sin embargo ambas granjas
compensaron parte de este déficit
mediante la compra de cantidades iguales
de manzanas de las granjas de estados
vecinos que se puede decir el número de
manzanas en cada granja y tiene una
granja de mayor cantidad de manzanas que
la otra o tienen la misma cantidad y
cómo lo sabes muy bien entonces vamos a
resolver esto vamos a vamos a primero
definir algunas variables entonces voy a
definir estas variables sea m igual al
número de manzanas el número de manzanas
en granja arce
esto es en granjearse y ahora sea r
igual al número de manzanas de huerto
río grande así que eres igual al número
de manzanas de huerto río grande y vamos
a voy a leer otra vez este primer
párrafo dice en los últimos años granjas
se ha cosechado alrededor de mil
manzanas más que su principal rival de
la región huerto río grande y ok
entonces podemos decir que m es
aproximadamente igual a r más 1000 ajá o
como como no sabemos la cantidad exacta
porque aquí dice alrededor de 1000
entonces podemos decir que en un año
normal granjearse denotado por m tiene
una mayor cantidad de manzanas que río
grande denotado por r entonces m es
mayor que r y esto sucede en un año
normal entonces por aproximadamente mil
manzanas más m es mayor que r en un año
normal ahora aquí
que que debido al frío bajaron la
cantidad por un tercio ambos así que m
es mayor que en un año normal pero este
año este año m ya rebajaron por un
tercio así que es lo mismo que decir que
ahora tenemos dos tercios de la cantidad
y voy a voy a poner aquí un ejemplo para
que se entienda un poco más digamos que
yo tengo equis y le restó un tercio de
equis así que me quedan dos tercios de
equis y ese es el ejemplo ahora muy bien
han bajaron por un tercio la cantidad es
lo mismo que tener dos tercios
si yo multiplico esta desigualdad por
dos tercios la desigualdad se mantiene
porque estoy multiplicando por un número
que es positivo y estoy multiplicando a
ambos lados de la desigualdad entonces
es como que tuvieras una balanza se
queda igual siguió multiplicada por un
número negativo entonces si cambiaría la
desigualdad se voltearía pero estoy
multiplicando por dos tercios dos
tercios de m es mayor que dos tercios de
r y lo que puedo hacer es dibujar aquí
una recta numérica tal vez esto parezca
un poco
si así lo es disculpa pero si no bueno
no no hace daño aprender así que bueno
en fin
digamos que aquí está por aquí al estar
m m tiene mil manzanas más que río
grande en un año normal y río grande
está por aquí ahora si le quitamos dos
tercios a m entonces estaremos más o
menos más o menos por aquí digamos esto
es esto sería dos tercios de m dos
tercios de m ahora dos tercios de r eso
dónde estaría eso está más o menos dos
tercios de él estaría más o menos por
aquí no es exacto pero supongamos
entonces puedes ver que dos tercios de r
sigue siendo menor que dos tercios de m
así bueno se mantiene la desigualdad
como puedes ver dos tercios de m es
mayor que dos tercios de r y ahora
seguimos leyendo dice sin embargo ambas
granjas compensaron parte de este
déficit mediante la compra de cantidades
iguales de manzanas de las granjas de
estados vecinos
así que ok sea
igual a la cantidad de manzanas igual a
la cantidad de manzanas que ambos
compraron
entonces ok
ambos compraron la misma cantidad de
manzanas podemos podemos sumar a a ambos
lados de la desigualdad y no va a
cambiar la desigualdad se va a mantener
siempre y cuando tú sum eso resta es la
misma cantidad a ambos lados de una
desigualdad la desigualdad se mantiene
entonces sumamos a dos tercios de m es
mayor que dos tercios r más a esta es la
cantidad de manzanas que tiene
granjearse después de comprar manzanas y
es la cantidad de manzanas que tiene el
río grande así que puedes verlo aquí y
granjearse sigue teniendo más manzanas
que río grande en un año normal y ahora
este año tiene dos tercios de la
producción pero luego compro una
cantidad de manzanas entonces por poner
un ejemplo digamos que digamos que hay
es esta cantidad esta cantidad entonces
digamos por ejemplo que que a granjearse
llega a m otra vez ajam y ahora si río
grande también compro la misma cantidad
de manzanas dos tercios r más a sería
sería esto llegaríamos aquí lo voy a
hacer un poco diferente digamos que no
quiero que que se solapen pero digamos
que granjearse compra a cantidad de
manzanas entonces esto esto es a esto es
a voy ahora a copiar para que sea la
misma cantidad
y río grande también compra la misma
cantidad de manzanas y entonces
simplemente copio esto y lo pego así que
ya tenemos el resultado tenemos que que
está así que esto voy a voy a poner que
una línea que corresponde a la cantidad
de manzanas que tiene el río grande esta
es la cantidad de manzanas que tiene el
río grande esto es igual esto es dos
tercios de r
lo voy a poner aquí dos tercios de r más
a corresponde a río grande y a
granjearse granjearse tiene dos tercios
m masa por lo tanto puedes ver que
granjearse sigue teniendo más manzanas
que río grande